[Música]
Guatemala fue a las urnas en la primera
vuelta de las elecciones generales
avanza el conteo pero el país a
centroamericano tendrá que esperar
varios días hasta conocer los resultados
oficiales
la guardia costera de Estados Unidos
habrá una investigación oficial sobre
las causas de la implosión catastrófica
del titán el sumergible que se hundió en
el Océano Atlántico con cinco personas
que se dirigían a los restos del Titanic
el continente americano conmemoró este
domingo el día del orgullo con marchas
fiestas y reivindicaciones millones de
personas defendieron los derechos lgbt
desde Santiago de Chile hasta Toronto en
Canadá
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición en Guatemala porque
el país fue a las urnas este domingo en
la primera vuelta de las elecciones
generales recordemos que 9,3 millones de
personas estaban llamadas a las urnas
pero solo la mitad acudieron a ellas es
decir la participación fue del 50% en
una jornada para elegir presidente y
vicepresidente miembros del parlamento y
las municipalidades a esta hora avanza
el conteo pero los resultados oficiales
tardarán varios días y con toda
probabilidad Habrá segunda vuelta el 20
de agosto para decidir el líder de un
país donde la economía creció un 4% en
2022 pero tiene altos niveles de
desigualdad y más del 50% de la
población en la pobreza un problema que
se suma y se relaciona con la corrupción
la migración o la desafección política
corrupción narcotráfico y migración
Estos son varios de los retos que el
próximo presidente de Guatemala tendrá
que hacer frente desde la salida de la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala
respaldada por la ONU los señalamientos
de corrupción han aumentado
principalmente en las altas esferas
políticas bajo el gobierno del
presidente Alejandro gianmatei se han
destituido varios jueces anticorrupción
y unos 40 funcionarios de la justicia se
han judicializado las medidas adoptadas
recientemente por el congreso el
Ministerio Público y otras autoridades
han obstaculizado la rendición de
cuentas por actos de corrupción y abusos
han atentado contra el estado de derecho
y han debilitado las garantías de
Derechos Humanos incluso Estados Unidos
sancionó a la actual fiscal general de
la nación María Consuelo porras bajo la
acusación de participar en actos
significativos de corrupción actualmente
se encuentra tras las rejas del
expresidente Otto Pérez Molina cumple
una sentencia de 16 años por ilícita y
defraudación aduanera Guatemala por su
posición geográfica es paso obligado de
cargamentos ilegales de drogas hacia
Estados Unidos con el aumento de esta
actividad en los últimos años Las
capturas con fines de extradición hacia
ese país ha descendido de manera
considerable según el ministerio público
en el año 2021 se detuvieron unas 57
personas 27 en 2022 y 7 reportados hasta
el mes de abril de 2023 en un territorio
donde el 59% de su población vive en la
pobreza parte de las iniciativas han
quedado solo en el papel A pesar de este
contexto adverso Washington mantiene
relaciones con Guatemala al estar
ubicado en el Triángulo Norte
centroamericano es un punto emisor y
receptor de migrantes rumbo al norte El
83% de estos citan la corrupción como
uno de los principales motivos para
salir del país el 77% lo hacen en busca
de oportunidades económicas Mientras que
el 54 y el 48% alegan la extorsión y el
delito respectivamente debido al alto
flujo de personas que migran hacia
Estados Unidos la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris lidera desde junio de 2022 el
proyecto de inversión corporativa
valorado en 3.200 millones de dólares
esto con el objetivo de crear empleos
en otras noticias en Estados Unidos la
guardia costera anunció una
investigación oficial para esclarecer
las causas de la inclusión catastrófica
del titán el sumergible cuyos restos
fueron encontrados el pasado jueves
Después de cinco días de búsqueda por
mar y aire en la inmersión de la empresa
privada oceangate recordemos
participaban cinco personas que se
dirigían a los restos del Titanic en el
fondo del Océano Atlántico
durante el curso de la investigación la
junta trabajará primero y principalmente
para determinar la causa de este
siniestro marítimo y las cinco muertes
asociadas sin embargo también es
responsable de los aspectos de
responsabilidad del incidente y puede
hacer recomendaciones a las autoridades
competentes para aplicar sanciones
civiles o penales según sea necesario
los accidentes ferroviarios son una
constante en Estados Unidos el más
reciente percance ocurrió en el estado
de Montana este mismo sábado dejando en
evidencia problemas con la
infraestructura en las vías del país
Rafael Pérez nos trae los detalles
otro descarrilamiento en las vías
férreas estadounidenses este sábado un
tren cayó a las aguas del río
Yellowstone tras salirse de la vía y
provocar el derrumbe del puente por el
que transitaba transportaba asfalto
fundido de azufre lo que disparó las
alarmas de los vecinos de la zona ante
una probable contaminación de las aguas
del cauce Este no es el único accidente
de este tipo reportado en el año en
febrero un tren con una carga superior
de materiales químicos altamente
inflamables se descarriló en el estado
de Ohio provocando un ambiente de
preocupación constante en la población
de
los 150 vagones que transportaba 50s
accidentaron algunos llevaban cloruro de
vinilo es común el descarrilamiento en
las vías norteamericanas hasta finales
del mes de abril de 2023 se habrían
reportado unos 78 siniestros de
disimiles magnitudes según el canal
local cnbc han ocurrido alrededor de
1000 accidentes anuales desde 2014
en casi una década esto representa un
promedio de 992 descarrilamientos cada
12 meses entre las causas fundamentales
se encuentra el aumento de las
capacidades de carga lo que representa
mayor ganancia a las empresas
coordinadoras una de las preocupaciones
que escuchamos fue que los ferrocarriles
pueden haber compensado la reducción de
personal mecánico al tener otros tipos
de personal como conductores que
realizan estos controles previos a la
salida la infraestructura de Estados
Unidos es también un factor a tener en
cuenta el deterioro y obsolescencia hizo
que el presidente Joe biden lanzar un
plan comprendido en 1,2 billones de
dólares para la reparación de carreteras
autopistas la modernización del
ferrocarril y puentes como el que se
derrumbó justo antes de la visita de
biden para promocionar su proyecto
y Santiago de Chile en Nueva York San
Francisco o Toronto fueron solo algunas
de las ciudades en las que millones de
personas defendieron los derechos lgbt
este domingo del mes del orgullo Manuel
acano tiene el informe
las calles de América teñidas de los
colores del Arcoiris de Sura Norte la
comunidad lgbtiq más del continente
conmemoró el mes del orgullo en Chile
las banderas de la comunidad ondearon en
Santiago la capital y los bailes se
apoderaron de las plazas de la ciudad el
país suramericano ha dado pasos hacia la
inclusión como la aceptación de una
cédula de identidad no binaria el año
pasado Sin embargo el camino sigue
siendo largo solo en 2020 el país
registró Un aumento de casi 15% en Casos
de uso contra personas de la comunidad
por lo que el pedido sigue siendo el
mismo
fuerza que después de aprobado el
matrimonio igualitario en Chile Eso no
significa bajo ningún punto de vista que
la discriminación más al norte Nueva
York miles salieron a las calles al
ritmo de la música una marcha que se da
en medio de un año especialmente difícil
para la comunidad según cifras de la
unión estadounidense por las libertades
civiles en 2023 se han presentado 491
proyectos de ley anti lgtbiqmash en las
legislaturas estatales nuestra comunidad
está bajo ataque y necesitamos aliados
necesitamos que toda la comunidad se
presente para defendernos un ambiente
similar se dio en el país vecino Canadá
en Toronto incluso las motos cargaban
los colores de la comunidad los
participantes enfatizaron en las
demandas que aún no han sido escuchadas
Me encantaría que existieran más
reconocimiento para las familias que son
diferentes a la Norma es decir las
personas que son lgbti más para las
personas que se encuentran en
situaciones en las que son poliamorosas
y quieren tener varias parejas
principales la conmemoración comenzó
luego de que el 28 de junio de 1969 una
redada policial en un bar conocido como
en Nueva York derivara en
multitudinarias manifestaciones durante
días contra el acoso y el hostigamiento
a la comunidad
[Aplausos]
llegamos así al final de esta emisión a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención y saben que pueden ampliar toda
esta y más información
[Música]